in the park we used to [ __ ] bury
dirty pictures that [ __ ] Thomas used
to take used to give us cuz he was the
older kid that had [ __ ] bad parents
and he we were like y'all give you a
picture of this chick if you [ __ ]
give me your potato skin bytes and I'd
be like yo say no more fam here are my
potato skin bytes so then I went and I
buried the [ __ ] pictures of titties
in a baseball [ __ ] card box and I
buried him in the back of [ __ ] Jannik
or Brook Park and the [ __ ] kid who
lived on the other side of janna Brook
Park told my dad about it Chris and Matt
are doing some bad [ __ ] and my dad said
oh yeah what they got dirty pictures of
girls in the back he Anika broke part
and my dad said oh yeah he said yeah he
said okay and he close the [ __ ] door
on and I said did you get mad and he
said of course I didn't get mad and even
if I was mad I wasn't gonna let that
[ __ ] kid know that I was mad because
he thought he was telling on you and I
wanted him to feel stupid dude I forget
his name I think it was Mike something
all [ __ ] shitty guys her name Mike cuz
we weren't gonna let that kid have his
cake and eat it too [ __ ] that kid [ __ ]
him as a seven year old on goofy [ __ ] I
[ __ ] went the next day I took potato
skins and I traded them for Thomas for
some more [ __ ] nudie pictures I came
home I took those nudie pictures and I
walked up to my dad's office my dad was
in his office I walked up I knocked on
the door open the door
I [ __ ] threw the nudie pictures on
his desk and I said those are the pics
and I walked out yup dude you think
you're gonna on earth some dirty tickets
tip 30 titties in a public park and get
me in trouble by telling my dad about
that [ __ ] Oh guess what [ __ ] I
still got some potato skins to spare